from Humble 19th century Beginnings
right through to the present day John
Lewis has been a Mainstay of the British
High Street
but at least part of its enduring appeal
has been that this was a business that
did things differently
we all together
how we run the business and the first
show of the Prophet too run by and for
its employees who are Partners in the
business itself that's why I've been
here for 17 years the John Lewis
structure was once hailed by then Deputy
Prime Minister Nick Clegg as a model for
the entire British economy but that
model could not be under threat as
bosses are reportedly considering
selling off a minority stake in the
business in a bid to raise badly needed
funds for one former member of John
Lewis's top decision-making body that's
a step too far the essence of John Lewis
is a democratic partnership where
everybody within the firm has the right
to say what they feel and be accounted
for
um and if you then change the model that
has been in practice for the last
hundred years or so then you're taking
away the fabric of what the partnership
is and stands for like many retailers
John Lewis has struggled to recover from
the pandemic closing 16 stores the
Retail Group which runs the department
store chain and waitrose supermarket has
posted heavy losses each year since
2020.
this year it announced a pre-tax loss of
234 million pounds it said inflation had
sent costs soaring by 179 million pounds
at the same time its sales were down two
percent driven in particular by per
performance at waitrose staff will not
be paid their annual bonus for only the
second time since 1953. I think that
John Lewis partnership has really become
a bit more corporate in recent years a
bit more like other companies when uh in
my opinion it's traditional strength has
been that partnership model John Lewis
said in a statement that its Partners
would be the first to hear of any
developments but as the owners of the
business they will also be the ones who
decide its future Matthew Thompson Sky
News